okay good morning and welcome to this
joint audit and standards committee
i am councillor dave muller and i am
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the committee will be
filmed hold the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for web casting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd like to make a few introductions
please the officers attending the
meeting today
are katherine steele the assistant
director for corporate resources
john snell the corporate manager for
internal audit risk and data protection
melissa evans the corporate manager for
financial services and commissioning and
procurement
and john robinson the corporate manager
for democratic services
also attending the meeting are
representatives from the external
auditors
ernst and young can i move to the agenda
please
uh item number one apologies for absence
and substitutions i will now ask the
governance officer to roll call for the
members
present thank you thank you chair
members can you please reply with
present when i call your name
um counselor barrett we have received
apologies for
uh councillor hiron we are aware is
having problems joining the meeting
um councillor lindsay
so i'm i'm here thank you councillor
mccror
president councillor mclaren present
counsellor amoroson president
uh councillor casten has sent his
apologies
councillor matheson president
councillor mueller president councillor
thank you very much um moving on to item
number two
to receive declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest
by members are there any to declare
no okay thank you item number three
jac stroke 19 stroke 15
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the joint audit and standards
committee
held on the 27th of january 2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
chair i i've got three three points
which are
uh essentially follow-up rather than
um than accuracy right
uh we're really just looking at accuracy
on this particular one uh counselor
matheson
shall we have some opportunity to to
address the
items in there which we need follow-up
um well see on this particular one i
think we're just looking for accuracy
uh on the minute
elsewhere on the agenda um
possibly are they relevant to the
relevant other items on the agenda
well i think the answer the answer is
some of them and
but i have a couple that are not okay
well the ones that obviously relevant to
the otherwise in the journey yes please
please bring those up in the questioning
uh when we try it well the
um let's see
paragraph 1810 i'm just getting to it
myself
now
here we go um
oh so sorry about the delay right yes
1810 page 11
um i i asked about the
money that we were investing in gateway
14
and the the answer at the time
was that it was considered short term
and really i wanted to understand
at what point how long would be
defined as short term or long term
does that actually affect the accuracy
of these minutes it doesn't affect the
accuracy of the minutes but i it's a
question
if if if if the assistant director wants
to take the question
and and reply to me subsequently and the
rest of the committee
that that would be okay but it's it is
it is something that remains the
question
okay um thank you for that case of
matheson um um
catherine uh would you be able to answer
um
councilman's question outside of this
meeting please and copy all the other
committee members into that yes
certainly chad no problem
thank you very much does anybody else
have any questions thanks to lindsay
yes thank you chair um i'm afraid it's
similar to
to councillor madison uh on
16 page 16 of the minutes
um there's um potential recommendation
3.8 that's in paragraph 21
14 21.14
um the the the recommendation 3.8 the
officers and members
working parties etc etc um
take greater account of the council's
own declaration of a climate change
emergency
um has that been action that's my
question
or do we have a follow-up on that well
again we're just looking at the accuracy
at this time
um catherine can you would you be able
to provide
answers to that again outside of this
meeting please and copy all members of
the committee into that
so this one um refers to climate change
so i would probably need to talk to
cassandra clements because she's the
assistant director leading on that piece
of work okay
thank you catherine is that okay with
you council lindsay
yes thank you thank you councilman
you've got your hand up again
yeah the um yeah on the point just just
discussed
um because i i was in the middle of um
of asking for that additional um
recommendation
so um clearly i'm particularly
interested to see
um the the follow through on that but i
do have
one other which is 17.27
and i requested that the external
companies
accounts um that they were apparently
going to be scrutinized by joint
overview
and scrutiny committee um
and a report and i asked a report was
then brought to us
this committee um of of their
deliberations i'm not clear that any of
that's
happened or not
catherine can you highlight on that one
please
[Music]
thank you chair is that in relation to
the group accounts
councillor matheson well it was i think
that
the minute says external company
accounts and obviously that's
there's some five or something companies
all together that it refers to isn't
it we i say we have got on the agenda
obviously
uh ey's final audit report on the 1819
accounts and they do do some work
around our companies as part of the
group accounts
work and we've also got their audit
plans so
that might be something for them to to
comment when we get to that item on the
agenda chair
yes i'm happy with that uh catherine
thank you
yeah we we can um yeah we can return at
that
at that point it does it i think it
the discussion really was that i i was
asking
young about the those other companies
and
we established that other other auditors
would be auditing those
and um and that the the appropriate
place for those
subsidiary audits was scrutiny
um i comment so so that's that's why the
minutes
says as it does sure can i come so we'll
come back to that
yes uh cash liver cruel thank you very
much
chair um it's just on that very point
the the
record states that this was a request
that when
the company external accounts or the
external company accounts
had been scrutinized by joint overview
and scrutiny
it wasn't actually established that
joint overview and scrutiny would be um
scrutinizing those accounts i'm not sure
that that was necessarily in the
procedures
uh for scrutiny it may actually be
better suited to audit and standards in
the first case
but it's a conditional case all i can
say is that uh a scrutiny of the
external company accounts has not taken
place
since that meeting and the minutes is
all we're recording here
yeah correct thank you thank you case
mccall
that seems fair enough at the moment yes
okay
thank you so does anybody else have any
comments about the accuracy of the
actual minutes
no right could i have a proposal for the
minutes please
happy to uh propose thank you councillor
norris uh a second to place
i'm happy to second chair okay thank you
councilman crawl
um could the governor's officer now take
a roll call vote please
thank you chair please can you reply for
against or abstain
council amerosin what
um councillor lindsay stoned because i
wasn't there
thank you councillor mccraw
four councillor mclaren for
councillor matheson four councillor
muller
four
thank you very much thank you i'd like
to move on now to
item number um well the minutes of the
meeting have been confirmed and will be
signed at the next practicable
opportunity moving on to item agenda
item
number four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition
scheme can i ask the governance officer
please to um
comment on that one please yeah
non-received chair
none received thank you very much uh
item number five
questions by the public none received
thank you
and item number six questions by
councillors
none received thank you very much mandy
we now move on to agenda item number
seven
which is jac stroke 1916
joint annual governance statement 19
20. i would now like to invite john
snell the corporate manager for internal
audit
to present the report thank you
thank you and good morning councillors
excuse me
so this report reviews each council's
corporate governance arrangements
during uh 2019 2020
as required by the counts and audit
regulations 2015
and is presented as a joint statement to
reflect the
governance arrangements in place across
both councils
furthermore it provides an insight into
looking ahead for this year and the key
challenges facing both councils moving
forward as well as addressing those
challenges
which were identified during 2018-19 and
the resultant actions taken at that time
this committee has a responsibility for
being satisfied that the statement
properly reflects the governance
arrangements in place
baba and mid-suffolk have adopted a
local code of corporate governance that
sets out the
a commitment to corporate governance and
summarizes the government's arrangements
and activities in place to which it's
accounted for
accountable too so it engages with its
communities
the local code is consistent with the
principles of the sit for solace
framework delivering
good governance in local government
2016.
this statement explains how the councils
have complied with the
local code and also meets the
requirements of the accounts and audit
regulations referred to earlier 2015
to reflect the code the ags includes
assurance statements from various
officers
representing the oversight functions as
well as the annual
audit opinion from myself the senior
leadership team as part of the
consultation process have reviewed this
and have made comments and these are
actually incorporated within the report
that you see in front of you
today the ajs also provides an assurance
of the effectiveness of the
council's systems on internal control
the arrangements continue to be regarded
fit for purpose in accordance with the
framework there have been no governance
issues identified during the year
that are considered significant in
relation to each council's overall
governance
the covid19 emergency has meant that the
council
has had to make a number of changes to
its governance arrangements
this governance statement provides
assurance over the government's
arrangements that have been in place for
the majority
of 2019 and 20 and it also identifies
the assurance statements from officers
the issues and the changes that have
been implemented in response to the
emergency
the council's arrangements are under
significant pressure as we all know but
i think it's felt that they are still
robust and sufficient for the current
circumstances we face
as we look forward and fully assess the
covet 19 impact this gives us the
opportunity for both councils to look
to transform how we deliver our services
by reviewing
remodeling and reven reinventing the way
the council operates
to provide better services to our
customers increase social value
reduce our costs without compromising
services
and look to increase and stroke and
generate income
are there any questions that relate to
the annual government statement that's
presented for you
thank you thank you thank you john um
can i open up do any members have any
questions for
um john snell please
counselor matheson yeah thank you i i
have
i have several i'd perhaps um
perhaps we should um take it in turn so
to speak
i'm just taking them in in order down
the
um down the page um
the sorry yes let's get there we are
yeah on 4.6 um
i mean i realize this is somewhat
controversial point but
the ensuring openness comprehensive
stakeholder engagement
um i feel that
as a member of the group that's half the
council at mid suffolk
um i'm not really feeling that engaged
in the
governance process at the moment
actually sorry
i do i do have to make that point okay
someone will start to have a turn
anybody else would like to ask any
questions
of john please
please raise the hand on the team's bar
counter lindsay
thank you chair um yeah just just
wondering if
um perhaps for future uh
annual governance reports well i mean
since
the year in question we've had the um
climate change recommendations and there
were a couple of governance
changes that were accepted by cabinet
there um uh including how we report on
um environmental impact which i think
the implication of the
um assistant director environment was
that
it wasn't adequate at the moment we tend
to get a blanket
it's fine and there was a recommendation
to set up
a proper um that to make sure
the environment team looked every
decision the cabinet makes
and its impact on carbon emissions
um so i wonder if in future reports we
could have
a report from the um
from the environment team or the
assistant director environment
uh yes absolutely counsellor yes i can
ensure that uh that happens for the
future
thank you council lindsay uh councillor
mccraw
just a commentary on the these last
couple of points and it's i'm just
because we may be in danger of confusing
governance which is what this statement
is about yeah
and the administration which is
the uh carrying out of policies the
government statement
to my understanding is a statement of
the
overarching structure of governance
within
um the understanding of the act this is
not it is not about
the translation of policies it just says
that we for example in 4.6 that
we can define outcomes in terms of
sustainable economic social and
environmental benefits that is there is
a
a mechanism for that but the actual
carrying out of that mechanism
and the carrying out of policy is the
work of the administration
and those are two separate things at
least that's my understanding of them
yes i think that's a very good point
cash number call thank you for that
um does anybody any other member have
any other questions or do other
other members listening in any other
other questions
uh madison please yeah the the um
with with covid and so on 4 4 16
and 17 seem a bit bit strange actually
um because 417 rightly says
um that kobe has been major problems and
416 says there haven't been any any
significant issues so
i feel as if they're actually
contradicting one another which looks it
looks a bit odd it's a bit
presentational but it did strike me
reading through
um i have got um could i
sort of interrupt points regarding the
the actual statement as opposed to the
report
councilman could could um john please
come back to you on that one please
absolutely
when you've just raised thank you yeah
thank you thank you chair and thank you
um councillor matheson just to
um provide a bit of context the annual
government statement is actually looking
backwards
so we're looking at 2019-20
kofi 19 actually took effect really the
lockdown from
march so that only represented one month
of the 12 months from last year
so there was little emphasis to place at
that stage
on the actual annual government
statement but you'll see within the
actual statement itself
many of those key offices made a
reference to the kovit 19 as we move
forward and the challenges that brings
obviously we're now sort of moving into
the more recovery phase
but that still needs to be very mindful
in terms of how we deal with covert 19
and the fact it has
on our governance arrangements as we
move forward into this
financial year but in the main
the annual government statement looks
back it's a retrospective
period so of which only one month was
really
affected and we didn't really know very
much about kobe 19
during march and we know an awful lot
more now unfortunately
that's very helpful thank you thank you
do you have any further questions
counselor matters
on the statement as opposed to on the
report
i don't know how we're going with that
i'm just rolling forward onto the
statement now
um
so there are chair i had i had one
question on the
on the report if we leave it
okay yes um council mathematics did you
do you mind if your colleague came to
this course
yeah please go ahead coach lindsay thank
you um
so yes so on the um in the bit about
assets
um i was just wondering where uh
council properties like borumgate
where that fits in the governance i i
i'm
hopefully it's in there somewhere but i
couldn't spot where
it talks about the um labor growth
and um uh but but and
sifko but it doesn't talk about
governance concerning at properties that
aren't held in those
companies or is it somewhere else
are you sorry council are you referring
to the actual statement as opposed to
the covering report
uh it's page
well the bit i'm reading is page 43
uh i'm not actually i thought it was in
the report but
it's hard to tell when you're looking
online um
in the statement if
there's 45 definitely this thing
sustained biggie pardon um
yeah page 45. um
so it's just the opinion yeah the
opinion of the assistant director assets
and investments
yes um
okay so i'm just scrolling down babe
with me please
i would think that as it does say that
it's um
the whole kind of review these on a
quarterly basis with the counters
corporate manager so
um it is page 45 john uh sure
on the actual statement okay fine
chair i may be able to assist on this
one yeah thank you catherine
um just to say that um borum gate is
owned directly by baber district council
so that would be subject to the normal
governance arrangements
so obviously the assistant director for
assets investments has
has responsibility and then reporting
would be into the senior leadership
team and then into into cabinets if that
helps
thank you does that help you answer your
question council lindsay
uh yes thank you yeah thank you um i'll
go back to councillor matheson and then
do counselor
mclaren after that counselor matthew
your your question please
thank you yeah so on to the government
statement um
page 29 30 um
the there's a description of the
political makeup and um administration
of the
two councils and i think if we're going
to
say that um baby has
no overall political control then we
need to say
how mid-suffolk is controlled by the
conservative cabinet i.e
on the chairs casting vote potentially
um
it's just just a mismatch of um the
descriptions really
thank you i can look into that yeah
thank you yeah thank you thank you john
um councillor mclaren thank you chair
um i was just i've got some questions
but i was just clarifying that we
formally gone into the
statement itself for discussion no we
haven't gone to debate yet we're still
in actual questions at the moment
yeah but we're actually continuing with
the statement
yes yeah we can yeah it's all part of
the uh
okay so can i uh to john can i ask
um there is on page 30
there's a description of a counselor
development working group
do we have knowledge of which counselors
are on that
uh no i wouldn't have that knowledge at
hand though i can actually find
out for you that would be really helpful
because
page 30.
we do have it's a mixed um working group
from councillors from all political
groups on both
um from both councils and they meet on a
quarterly basis to
look at counsellor training and review
the training that's already happened
and make sure that we're keeping up with
anything current um so i'm happy to
send councillor mclaren those details
outside of the meeting
thank you very much thank you thank you
karen
can i have do you want to go back to
somebody else because i've got another
similar question to ask do you want to
ask that question now mr
counselor matheson probably give him a
chance
oh counselor matheson did you wish to
come back i'm just looking for my next
next question okay okay karen please
carry on
thank you very much um it's a similar
sort of question
um i've only been on this committee a
year
but i was looking at the on page 38 john
the suffer counter fraud group
again um and it's from each council i
think
do we know who is representing us oh
baby anyway
as far as i'm concerned on that group
yes certainly i can answer that question
so it's actually a member from my team
uh lily simeling
um this is a um an officer just purely
officer
okay that's fine no as long as i knew
who that was
and um i think so that's all at the
moment chair thank you very much thank
you casey mclaren
counselor matheson if you um your next
question please
thank you yes um there's there's a
couple of
points including the one i've just got
in my
sites at the moment on page 40
about um in that instance it's the
risk risk registers being regularly
reported to cabinets
and and this excuse me this committee
um i i think the regularly reported is
is is a bit tenuous
um or maybe you this is the same point
that looking back
um it hasn't been because we lost two
meetings
um this year but i guess maybe your your
previous point about this looking back
that looking back to 19 the year 1920
probably the the regularity of reporting
was okay so
so maybe i've answered my own question
have i there uh
yes you have counsellor yes and um just
to to point out as well um on the 11th
of august this committee will also
receive
a risk management report and update as
well
thank you oh what last year
yes yeah but actually the significant
risk register will be much more up to
date so i'll be able to give you a more
up-to-date version
than we would normally because of
obviously covert 19 um
obviously having problems in terms of
meeting and reporting stuff so
that will be much more up-to-date
registered for you to review and comment
on
counseling thank you john do any other
members have any other questions before
we move into debate
no therefore what i plan to do is so
thank you i will now open up
the item for debate and ask each of you
for your comments uh please uh could i
start with councillor
oliver amoroson please
do you have any um comments for the
debate um
thanks remember osun no none at this
time none at all thank you very much
um councillor um
matheson do you have any uh other things
for the debate
i think i i i perhaps just would come
back to the
um you know to my side i think it was
probably wrong
wrong to raise it as a question almost
um
but the um you know the question of
stakeholder
engagement um if if
members are stakeholders
and opposition members in particular
estate viewed as stakeholders then
um i i think the with the
um with the cabinet structure um
that this this you know the engagement
that we we have at the moment
which really consists of um the
only the scrutiny and audit functions
uh the group is represented um
is um is is tenuous
and and if if the principles are to
ensure
comprehensive stakeholder engagement
then i i think we're falling short at
the moment okay
okay moving on um councillor lindsay
do you have any debate
um well well actually
i had i've just realized i had a
question but it could also be for debate
um which i i left out um
and nick in the bit on coronavirus um
the last paragraph so we're talking
about page
39 age 39
um the last paragraph on a bit about
coronavirus
um it mentions that kovid um
could have uh actually the second to
last part
says um the fraud a fraud a threat
posed during emergency situations is
higher than
other times all public properties should
be attuned to the risks
and then the last part talks about
audit providing resources to the
council's business cell
to kind of take some extra
uh do some extra checks on on i think
people claiming business grants
um and it's just that you know you hear
rumors
people claiming uh for a business grant
for
somewhere they're actually using as a
second home that they aren't using as a
bnb or
or guest house or whatever um because
we've had
obviously we've we've doled out millions
uh in business grants so i just wanted
to kara could you
could you sort of um reassure us on that
but
um but you are i find it hard to imagine
how
you can possibly check all these people
whether they're really um claiming when
they should be
yeah there's certain um counsel of a
certain amount of checks that we can do
i mean obviously as you can say the
central government have provided
uh some funds um obviously for those
emergency payments
um because unfortunately um as i'll talk
a little bit on
the managing risk of fraud and
corruption paper
um there are fraudsters out there that
will take advantage of those emergency
measures
sadly so there are a number of checks
because of
[Music]
the remit if you like from central
government was to get that money out to
those in most in need quickly
a lot of the checks obviously have been
post post checks rather than pre-checks
and the government have set up a number
of um
areas that we can tap into that we can
actually do a number of checks on those
individuals
they also is a requirement for them to
sign an undertaking a declaration
that they believe that they are entitled
to that money show
should in the event of any post checks
come out that they weren't then
obviously we will try and make every
attempt to reclaim that money
because of the seriousness of this i
mean i have to actually say
in terms of the figures that i've
received and i'm saying this touch would
and it's almost like the auditor's curse
here we haven't experienced
many problems at all in terms of
fortunate claims
which i'm very pleased to report but i
do have a dedicated resource from the
audit team that's actually looking at
that
as part of the business cell with her
audit
and fraud hat on so to speak
so the initial area of work was look at
end-to-end processes to make sure that
they were actually sufficiently
robust in terms of what we were checking
and then obviously the checks that we
perform
as well to uh try and ensure where
we can um that those claims are genuine
and not fortunate in nature okay
thank you thank you uh counter lindsay
um i may want to move on to
councillor mccraw i'll come back to you
councillor madison because obviously
you've asked several
points uh councilman mccraw do you have
anything for the debate uh well if we're
in debate
chair um it's just really to return to
the purpose of the annual government
statement
and appendix a is if anybody is minded
ever to look
closely at it in fact it's a statement
this is my understanding it's a
statement
but it's a very important sort of
guideline to how the council
fits together where the various
departments which section that works
with what
what exists and we're stating what is
existed in that
financial year that council year so
uh and i'm always satisfied because i
think it works hand in glove
with the constitution you put those two
together and you have a pretty fair idea
of at least what the structure is now i
am not necessarily saying
that the structure always operates
precisely
to what is presented in the annual
governance statement it is a statement
it is an ideal
um and yes there are times where we can
fall short and we can look for
improvements
but as a statement and as an explanation
of the framework under which this well
this council baber and
obviously the mid-suffolk council
jointly operate
i think it's a fair and reasonable one
so i'd like to propose that
recommendations 3.1
and 4 be uh voted upon
and i would like to propose that motion
now
thank you uh i would yeah thank you for
that council mccall but i would like to
give the
opportunity to other colleagues that
haven't spoken yet just in case
they if that's okay okay
on that on that basis and having looked
through the through the statement
as before i'm satisfied that it should
be uh
voted upon yeah thank you yeah i have
thank you very much counselor karen did
you wish to make any comment
yes thank you chad um
first of all i'd like to say to john
that i found
the statement very comprehensive and
helpful to me as you know
trying to work my way through all the
papers but on page 42
um around commissioning and procurement
that came up at our last meeting when
there was some
um audit of performance
and it felt it was not rigorous enough
at that time so i've got to say i'm very
pleased to see on page 42
john that um there's a
an x phase sort of planned
where there will be an upgrading of
order
just the auditing of the performance of
procurement
and relationships with external
contractors
thank you jeff thank you very much thank
you uh i i'll go to
um councillor norris next please case do
you have any comments to make sure nice
sorry my uh laptops on the go good slow
um i had a point around covered 19 but
that's already been covered
by councillor lindsay i take this
opportunity just to mention a couple of
typos within the statement if that's
okay
page 35
second paragraph from the bottom we're
missing a word out of the sentence it
reads the corporate manager for
internal and data protection well we're
missing the word
audit okay
and page 44
just scroll down
uh second paragraph
[Music]
forget that one that's fine thank you
thank you uh
uh before i make my comments um
counselor matheson did you wish to make
another comment as part of the debate
before i make yeah
i i i think that um council mcgraw's
point um is is a good one
um i think that a number of the
questions
and comments that have been made so far
uh really point to places where
partly because of covid and and partly
because of
changes that there have been and so on
um they point to where um
the um the statement will need to
have significant re-drafting before it
emerges in 12 months
time so um that that i think is is the
other general
general point that i would make about it
at the moment
yes yes there's a description of what's
what's been
um and but the current situation is has
resulted in quite a lot of changes thank
you thank you very much counselor
madison
i'd like to make my comments now i would
like to thank john for his excellent
report
it was very detailed and i stressed that
the opinion of the chief financial
officer
is that the councils continue to operate
robust internal controls
and good public financial management so
so thank you for that
everybody's had the opportunity to speak
this and we've had a proposal
if nobody else wishes to speak can i
have a second to please for the four
recommendations detailed
on page 19 of the papers
mclaren
yes i wish to support that thank you
very much
we have a we have a proposal councillor
mccraw and secondary
council mclaren um therefore i will now
ask the governance officer to conduct
the roll call zone please
thank you chair please could you reply
for
against or abstain councillor american
thank you councillor lindsay four
okay councillor mccrore four
councillor mclaren four councillor
matheson
four
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you very much
uh i'd like to now move on to item
agenda number eight
which i'm just trying to scroll through
to find
um just bear with me a second
okay so number eight
is
the jsat 1917 annual internal
audit for 20 1920 again i now invite jon
snell the corporate manager for internal
audit
to present the report thank you john
thank you again chair so the purpose of
this report
is to provide counsellors with details
of the work undertaken
by internal audit for the year 2019
20. which is required under the public
sector internal audit standards
the report also provides details of the
reviews of other corporate activities
which
are supported by the work of the team
some of the key messages i'd like to get
across to to members today
include one around the demand on
internal audit services to provide
assurance
support and guidance continues as the
councils continue to reshape and
transform
its services and in line with the
council's
internal audit charter the work has been
conducted to ensure that it delivers
against the public sector internal audit
standards and the requirement for me
to produce an annual head of internal
audit year-end opinion
so our work covers governance processes
monitoring arrangements
ethics information governance risk
management and fraud management
the fraud management i'll talk to you
which is the next paper
and so i'll discuss that a little bit
more in detail the risk management i
think as i said earlier will be coming
to this committee
on the 11th of august
in terms of available resources during
the year you'll note that the specialist
lead for internal audit retired in june
last year
and that the specialist lead for risk
management was successful in applying
for a job within the finance team
effective from the beginning of december
a recruitment campaign to replace the
specialist for internal audit approved
unfortunately unsuccessful
as a result i produced a report for
senior management to consider the
options open to the councils for the
future provision of its audit service
now subject to further discussions uh
our shared
service model seniors management agreed
that the option of working with an
external partner
made good sense and one that would
potentially best suit the business needs
of both councils
a combination of a core in-house team
boosted by an external sort resource
would allow us to achieve a level of
flexibility
which can be critical in effectively
dealing with a range of operational
issues
and enables us to valuable to have
valuable and diverse specialized skills
as required from the external partner if
required
the contract was due to start in april
2020 but due to the covet 19
pandemic this has now been put back and
i'm pleased to say that the contracts
were actually signed on the 1st of july
this year with the reduction resources
i've carefully tried to manage the the
delivery of the audit plan in terms of
risk and available skills and experience
within the team
to ensure coverage at the end of the
year and
to really ensure that the audit opinion
is not compromised
so looking at appendix a
moving to appendix a looking at those
audits with an adverse
audit opinion you'll see that there were
six audits carried forward from 2018-19
as a result of the follow-up work two of
the audits have been closed following
positive management actions taken
against the
recommendations three audits will be
revisited following the conclusion of
the management review
however i would draw councillor's
attention to the proactive work
undertaken
planned by the corporate manager for
finance that's melissa evans with regard
to the contract sourcing
and spend reviews which i think council
mclaren touched on earlier
with regards to the housing work i've
arranged for the external order provided
to undertake a health and safety
compliance review which is drawn
by the conclusions are just being drawn
up as we speak now so there should be a
report imminent
for this year 2019 20 you'll see that
we've issued two audit reports with an
adverse
opinion which will begin followed up
this this year
and these four of the full details of
the completed audits you'll find in
section 6 of appendix a
as well as conducting audit reviews
internal audit
has significant involvement and variety
of different order activities
and just naming a few of these the
production of the annual government
statement which we've just sort of
spoken and discussed about
my attendance at the statute offices
working group where governance matters
require professional determination and
also as my role as the deputy council
oh sorry the council's definitely
monitoring officer
uh to help ensure councils their
officers and elected councillors
maintain the highest standards
of conduct we've also had the
development of the council's corporate
values
and again i dedicated a member of my
team to help support that project
with regard to risk management and
probity work these areas are subject to
separate reports
and obviously the fraud as i mentioned
will be coming next and
the risk later in august 11th of august
you'll see that in terms of performance
audit clients continue to express a high
level of satisfaction
with the service delivered the latest
figures are based on a 70
return of the completed customer
satisfaction surveys that we receive
after each audit internal audit continue
to perform
well against the key performance
indicators
the you'll see that the reduced
percentage of the audit plan delivered
is a result of the reduction in
available audit resources which i've
actually mentioned
and also the timing of the management
review which include a review of
internal audit service provision
in terms of the annual ordered opinion
i'm satisfied that the sufficient
assurance work has been carried out to
allow me to form a reasonable conclusion
on the adequacy
and effectiveness of each council's
internal audit environment
is therefore my opinion that the
council's framework of governance
risking management and risk management
and internal control is sufficient
it provides reasonable assurance the
system's processes or activity
should achieve its objectives safely and
efficiently
when we have some control weaknesses
most of those controls are put in place
and operating
effectively now and they were identified
and actually agreed with management
so i'm pleased to report that there's
been a positive response
to those areas where we considered that
the controls weren't robust enough
i'm happy to take questions on the
report
counsellors thank you john do you
members have any questions for john
on item number eight please
counseling pro
thank you chair i i too am having my
issues scrolling through because this is
a lengthy report but
i was looking at those areas john where
we have limited assurances
because obviously in most of the cases
we do have sufficient
reasonable assurance that uh matters are
in hand
and i was just noting the two i could
note
particularly were limited assurance in
the area of i.t
which uh seems very very important
right now i have to say um follow-up
planned early 2020
2021 well they suspect that's going to
take an even greater priority
and the second one i noted with the
limited assurance you do excuse me
my second screen is freezing on me
and page 71
was customers and well-being workplace
security
and i just have to say that obviously
with everything in our minds at the
moment regarding kobit 19
it seems to me that both of those uh
come into even sharper relief
i just wondered if john you could
comment on what we're able to do to
bring
our assurance up to something that's not
limited
yes certainly counselor i mean in terms
of take the first point the
the it um this is more around
the infantry of equipment that we had
and
there were some concerns that obviously
we all have lots of equipment but
actually trying to have a reciprocal
arrangement where
we are looking at what the officers have
got and what the i.t
say that we've got there really wasn't
very much
coalition between the both and also
slightly concerned about in terms
of the amount of money that we were
paying
so we do have a new
corporate manager for it uh matt harding
and i have been working with him
he has a copy of the report he's very
mindful of
the issues that we have raised within
that report and i'm working with him and
i have it
already he's actually drawn up an
infantry checklist
which is a very positive step so we can
actually start to
look what we have uh within the offices
and within the office itself
um the second point
um you raised was round about security
arrangements was that on page 71
councillor sorry um
i'm having problems i appreciate it was
page 71 john
and it was concerning workplace security
and uh obviously everything in that area
is um
subject to considerable review already
i'd have thought
with me please counsellor 6.1.3
customers and well-being on page oh
sorry is that 171
no it's 71. oh that's a little my
documents
um
and it was paragraph 6.3 1.3
um it's the list of the audit opinions
on assurances that's whether they'll be
and i'm focusing on two limited ones
yeah absolutely
certainly counselor sort of just
refreshing my mind as well
um okay so one of the issues in terms of
the summary of the key findings was
around about council responsibility for
health safety issues for
endeavour house were unclear yes
hopefully i'm on the right uh
that is it and it also referred to the
creating street uh [ __ ] road depot
um okay what we actually found
um counselors was um going back
last year now obviously um
last summer where if memory serves me
right uh in the canteen area
endeavour house if you're all familiar
with that that the the doors were opened
um obviously to let some fresh air in
but unfortunately a member of the public
just walked straight in and obviously
didn't go through the proper channels
and through
in terms of the barriers and was
actually able to get up to the first
floor
by asking a number of questions
regarding a council tax inquiry
so we obviously raised this with our
health and safety officer
and we're trying to establish what
security arrangements
there were in place bearing in mind what
we are a tenant
and suffolk county council obviously the
building and there seemed to be some
confusion over
whose responsibility it was now we were
clearly saying it wasn't ours
but we also wanted to make
representation to say that
um if there was a working group could we
ensure
that such items were addressed and there
seemed to be some confusion within
babe suffolk who our representative was
and how they would sort of fit into a
working group within suffolk county
council so
that's the issue that we had um at that
uh
particular instance and there's still
some some confusion i think in terms of
who's going to take ownership of that
and there's something obviously we just
want to
to address in terms of treating
road again i actually sent one of my
auditors just out there to do a number
of checks
just in terms of being able to get into
the building as well whether we're going
to be challenged if we had our badges or
not
what the level of insurance was around
i.t security
where the monitors were just left open
and worked shut and closed and there
were a number of issues that we raised
there
and we again spoke to the corporate
manager there who has made
some changes in terms of the security
arrangements around creating house
that wouldn't allow again um
people know whether it be members of the
public um just coming to walk into the
depot without being challenged
we're working as i say with the
corporate manager on that and he's
already made some uh
differences to allow so the security
arrangements are far more robust
uh john i just wanted to can i come back
with the supplementary council
yes are we
taking this further given the kovid 19
situation where we have another layer of
security requirement
are you trying to creating house now or
i'm talking both actually i think both
both sir endeavor house and in fact any
council
offices um we have a security need
from the point of view of public health
yeah certainly the security arrangements
endeavor health
are undertaken by
um oh vertex
sorry struggling um they are responsible
for the security of the building and
obviously report to council
uh soviet county council in that and
again uh what we were trying to
establish if there were any sort of
breaches or concerns then obviously that
would be related to babe
mid-suffolk as a tenant and all tenants
within endeavour house
and again certainly with creating
creating road
um yes i think there are clear guidance
in terms of
the information that have been provided
from
our senior leadership team through to
our offices
as well and at the moment obviously the
endeavor house
you'll be aware that we will not be
returning to endeavour house
for the foreseeable future
thank you i just wanted to ensure that
steps were being taken and wondered what
they might be
but uh obviously that's that's a moot
point at the moment
yes there has been something recently uh
come out from arthur
in in terms of um coming back to the
office and the phases that potentially
that would happen
so um it might be worth at this stage
just having sight
of that catherine i don't know if you
could just jump in
the the slides in the video that were
provided by arthur were they
extended to members as well to your
knowledge
it was a staff briefing i think that
arthur put out so i'm not sure off the
top of my
head
i don't think any member is aware of
having received any update since
uh endeavor house has been strictly
forbidden to us all
right
in the weekly um report or possibly a
special report
um that the chief executive put out
there was a link to a video
um quite a long video many 25 minutes of
video i think it was
which which did actually discuss this in
very great detail and um
i'm looking forward to eventually
writing him quite a few comments on it
but
um it's it's it is available to
to members um but there's just a little
tiny
link that you needed to click thank you
i must admit i did actually see that i
it was quite a lengthy though it's 45
minutes in total i believe
um i i did see that i haven't watched it
myself but
i did see the link uh on that so thank
you for that came to madison councilman
sorry did you want to come back please
sheriff my apologies yeah you're happy
with that
um i came to madison you have a question
yes the um i'm not
whether it's going to be a comment or a
question but i i was quite
um surprised and struck by
by um officers comment regarding
um the answer you know the the loss of
staff
which obviously i knew of the retirement
but
the unsuccessful recruitment and the
external partner
um i hadn't hadn't heard i wasn't aware
of that at all
now the chief executive has been
um quite um vigilant latterly
let's say over the last 12 months or
something now in
um in reporting in in the weekly um
staff and members briefing um no that
goes round
um the some of the arrivals and
departures
which which was was in response to
members asking
for that um i think that the particular
internal audit situation has son of
slip to slip through not not been
reported there
but i think it is of of particular
interest and obviously
um has contributed to page 73
where we we find that the um
the percentage completion of the audit
plan
uh is um you know has suffered
um and say these were matters that
um would create some member anxiety
and i'd have kind of been more happier
to know about it soon and let's put it
that way
thank you very much council madison does
any other member have any questions
on on this agenda item um i've got
several actually
um linked to basically what counselor
mccraw was saying
um um john just to go through some of
these recommendations
um particularly the limited assurance
ones
um 2.11 which is on page 62.
um the present status at this report
date
i'm reading the paragraph down there
considerations will still need to be
given to capital costs of service
improvement
which now fall across the multiple
services following the management
restructure
it's a recurring theme i found set on
several of these limited
assurance things perfectly happy with
your report
but i personally would find it helpful
if we could have a date when some sort
of further information
could be made available to us i'm sort
of harping back to my days working for
both department of health audit and
district audit the audit commission and
certainly that the site we would look to
would be to have dates uh when some of
this further information could be
available
um don't know what your thoughts are on
that john yeah happy to do that um
yes just to bring a bit of clarity uh
and assurance for yourselves
so so that's that's one thing that i
would and that's the same really with
with some of the
others um the other one i think was
there was one
about oh yes hospitality a gifts and
hospitality i think this is one i raised
last year um i think it's important that
obviously apart from members of staff
and i appreciate there is a risk
a register for hospitality etc
but i think obviously councillors should
also be included
in that if they do actually receive any
gifts etc
um i i know it happens i i go back to
when i was mayor of stone market three
years ago
um i did receive a couple of gifts from
various organizations which i did
declare
on the gift hospitality
register at stone market town council
they weren't they were only just over 25
pounds which is i believe it's the limit
still
but i do think that's really important
that councillors are fully aware of that
as well as the officers yeah absolutely
i think in the past
in the past as well i have actually
issued um some
some guidance as well for both
councillors and and officers as well
alike
particularly coming up to christmas at
that time of period is often um quite
fruitful
shall we say in terms of generosity yeah
and 2.1.5 which
was the housing one again it's just
really um
do we have um a completion date um or
proposed completion date for that on
2.15
i can actually provide a little bit of
update on that
um a draft report is currently with the
assistant director for housing and also
some of his
corporate managers as well to to comment
on the first draft
so that should be imminent thank you
very much for that
do any other members have any questions
on the this particular item number eight
no then we can go into debate um
does any other member wish to debate
this particular item before we go to the
recommendation
no right i'm just trying to find the
recommendation going
scrolling back through my papers right
the recommendation
is that the contents of this internal
audit report supported by appendix a
be agreed i'm happy to propose that
amendment
could i have a second to please i'm
happy a second
thank you thanks for norris um therefore
could i ask the governance officer
um to go through the list of members as
a vote please
thank you chair councillors if you could
please reply for
against or abstain uh councillor
amirosen
thank you councillor lindsay for
councillor mccrore four councillor
mclaren
or councillor matheson four
councillor mueller or councillor norris
paul thank you chair that's unanimous
thank you very much
uh mandy i'd like they'd like to move on
to item number nine
jac stroke 19 stroke 18 and managing the
risk of fraud and corruption
and your report and again i invite jon
snow the corporate manager for internal
audit to present his report please
thank you sean thank you chair um i
think thankfully this is the last report
of mine
um so i've just taken uh some water
all right okay so counselors um
this report outlines the current
arrangements in place
across both councils to ensure there is
a proactive
corporate approach to preventing fraud
and corruption and also provides details
of the
proactive work undertaken during the
year
to provide some context around general
fraudulent activity in
local government cipra produce or
produces annual national statistics
based on return surveys of which we
participate in
which indicate that the total estimated
value of four detected
or prevented by local authorities in
2018 19
is 253 million which actually was 49
million less than last year's total
um hopefully indicating that the
internal controls are stronger
and more uh risk targeted i think the
decrease in the
total value can largely be attributable
to the successful working in housing
with regard to reduction in the number
of unlawful sublet properties
and false right to buy applications
which still feature highly as
areas of fraud risk for all councils up
and down the land
i can give assurance to members the
previous scheduled work in these areas
have been undertaken by internal audit
and as a result a number of due
diligence checks have been implemented
to further strengthen the control
environment in those areas
fraud and corruption um in terms of
risks are identified as part of the
planning process
this is supported by a fraud risk
register which
contains a list of areas where we and
corporate managers believe the councils
could be susceptible to fraud the
register also helps managers to focus on
suitable internal controls to mitigate
any subsequent
uh risks of fraudulent activity
part of our work also includes raising
awareness across the councils and
includes for example
forwarding relevant um alerts which we
receive
by the national fraud bulletins to
ensure that our own
internal controls are adequate and
robust
reminders to both councils and staff
their responsibilities around getting
hospitalities which
the chair quite rightly pointed out and
again this has been an area subject to
an audit that
the results that you'll find in the
previous report
i presented to you um the recent
developed corporate values was used as
an opportunity to remind staff
of the council's whistleblowing
arrangements
and how we as an organization want to
create an open and supported culture
where staff feel comfortable in raising
concerns when they feel something is
wrong
without fear of any consequences the
councils through the shared revenues
partnership continued to give out strong
messages about fraud in both publicity
issues
and also internal documents regarding
council tax and housing benefit claim
forms
to help fight fraud and corruption
locally each council
i think i referred to this earlier
across south across suffolk sorry have
nominated representative to sit on the
suffolk counter ford group
and it's intended to hold these meetings
about three to four months every
every month the main objectives are to
explore the possibility of sharing and
matching data explore the possibilities
for joint working and sharing resources
given that resources across suffolk
are limited share material resources
ideas promoting broad and aware fraud
and awareness among staff and
counsellors
to do some joint training again cutting
down costs
and also sharing best practice in
relation to working arrangements
investigations
case management and to perhaps
investigate cases jointly where it is
found appropriate going back to the
council shared revenues partnership the
team has been recognized by the
dwp depart from working pensions
for their work to reduce fraud and error
in housing
payments so a real big pat on the back
to them they're doing that
to be honest a very fabulous uh job in
that area
the team have also been thanked by the
dwp for their continuous efforts in
tackling fraud and error
across the districts and also being
asked to work with them to develop best
practice that's really testament to the
work they're doing
which the dwp can refer to when working
with other authorities
whose performance require improvement
so in terms again of the srp work they
continue to apply what's called a
risk-based
verification approach to hp claims which
allows more intense verification
activity to be
targeted to those claims which are
deemed to be high risk
of involving fraud and or error they
participate in this suffolk wide single
persons discount exercise during
last year 1920 although work continues
on a number of discounts have been
removed which is again pleasing
and again the number of value are
reported i think in paragraph 4.23 of
this report
internal audit continues to take a
leading role in the national fraud
initiative work
and has started to investigate those
identified matches
for the latest during the latest
exercise
you'll see that part in this report
internal order activity
uh we've recently worked uh with
instance borough council
therefore team to investigate a baby
council tax reduction scheme
as a result the ctr claim was cancelled
back in september
and an overpayment created resulting in
a rebuilt of over two thousand pounds to
baby
further cases have been referred to the
ibc team to investigate
in terms of looking forward and ahead
against a backdrop of reduced funding
uh we need to assess uh fraud risks
effectively and target resources where
they'll produce most benefit
we need to remain particularly alert to
the threat of fraud as a result of the
kovic 19 impact
and i think as i've mentioned before
sadly unfortunately fraudsters are
exploiting the spread of
uh kogit 19 in order to carry out fraud
and cyber crime
we've issued alerts to our residents to
help minimize the risk of becoming a
victim of such frauds and cyber crime
and the response to the kovic 19 the
government is providing
funding through the local authorities
who are responsible for business rates
to support businesses a member of the
internal audit team is supporting the
business cell to provide that level
assurance that funds
are only paid to eligible businesses
where we can and ensuring that
appropriate action is taken to recover
any funds where we think there has been
fraudulent activity or error
okay are there any questions relating to
this report please counselors
any questions for members
counselor matheson
yeah just the one really in
in terms of the
what shall i say discouraging
discouraging
fraud and so on um are we
are we being as active as we can be in
ensuring that the the people we
catch um that the reports
are are publicized um
appropriately because i i'm always a
great believer in in the
um you know that justice scene to be
done
or uh encouraging the others or however
one would
want to express that um that everybody
knows
that we we are um we are catching people
um and therefore it might be them that
we catch if they
do the wrong thing thanks yes certainly
yeah certainly counselor if there are
some um
more what i would call high profile
cases then
they would obviously be publicized and
obviously they would through sanctions
would go through the courts
and obviously um the press will take a
keen interest
in publicizing those widely in the local
papers
yeah thank you if i could just momentary
check i mean i think the
um you know the cases where we
you know and i think the classic one of
course is is the right to buy etc
and that that being exploited um
that we you know that we publish
obviously
you can't name names if if it doesn't
get to the point of
going to court because we intercept
earlier but
again um the fact that we
you know that last year we we
intercepted x number of
of um of claims that what would have
been potentially
for alternate if they'd gone ahead or
things like that um that we just go as
far as we can
in as i said encouraging people
with the thought that they will get
caught yeah
and also within the applications there
are clear declarations
uh in terms of if we find out later that
this is a fraudulent claim or we even
find out during
the case that it's a portraying claim um
i'm very pleased in the terms of the
the guys that deal with the right to buy
applications
um they have a set of due diligence
checks and
the staff involved are very keen
to to pick off those where they think uh
or they require further information
and the problem that we have sometimes
uh counsellor is that an application may
fall for whatever reason but it's
sometimes difficult to prove whether
they actually
didn't wish to pursue their application
because
they felt that they would actually be
found out there may be some genuine
reasons
and there may be some unsavory reasons
but it is difficult
at that stage to fully understand
whether they were intending to
submit a fraudulent claim so we have to
be very careful in terms of how we
report
um such cases yeah i say not not
i'm just coming back from reporting
individual cases
to to just giving the general sense that
we're on
we're on the we're on to the onto the
case of
preventing it well yeah certainly the
preventative measures are
strong um in in terms of the whole
process as well from looking at clear
evidence
and it's down to the applicant to
provide that necessary
evidence not us so they have to prove
genuineness of that application
thank you thank you for matt councilman
mccraw please
thank you chair uh i'd just like to ask
uh
officers and john in particular how you
would characterize
both council's exposure to fraud perhaps
in relation to other authorities
uh in similar circumstances and perhaps
in dissimilar circumstances
are we uh more at risk than others are
we less at risk
how would you characterize our exposure
i think generally council is a very good
question actually because
i don't have necessary statistics um
in suffolk for example other than
talking to
my counterparts their heads of it
through suffolk
generally and i have to be very minded
when i say this
historically babylon and suffolk have
low levels of fraud
um now that is and there's a very it's a
caveat
attached to that very statement is that
we have to determine what we can do with
the resources that we have available
um now if i had a dedicated 14
we might be able to find more i'm not
saying it goes on
but we might be able to investigate more
and actually look at more sensitive
areas
it's not until you turn the stone over
you you don't realize what's actually
underneath
but i can assure you that in terms of
what we're doing for babylon suffolk
in terms of the fraud risk register we
are actually targeting areas where we
think there is
potential fraud that could take place
within certain service areas and we're
trying to take every steps to obviously
mitigate those with strong controls that
are in place
there's always going to be examples
where people will
try and see opportunities we've just got
to try and plug those opportunities to
ensure
that our obviously control environment
is as secure as we can possibly make it
as i said iva's particularly obviously
alongside
the srp and also the itch which fraud
team who have a dedicated
um fraud section they're in a very
fortunate position
and often we'll i will have
conversations with them
in terms of if we have potential fraud
how we're going to
um pursue that with their expertise
but i think generally mid-suffolk baber
as i said historically
have low levels of fraud generally and
i'd like to think that's
the case in terms of the strong control
environment that we do have in place but
obviously that won't deter force because
i always find different ways of trying
to
look at opportunities counselor muller
may i just
ask a second question somewhat related
to this and more specific
yes thank you very much i apologize to
council mclaren for keeping her waiting
uh the particular concern i've become
aware of during the lockdown
was that uh in cases of subletting
for very good reasons our housing team
have been unable to act
um as they would normally have done
because that doesn't make
sense during a pandemic but i
wanted to ask is that uh do we see
ourselves being able to go forward and
to resume
as i would put it normal service in the
case of subletting which i
has been a there have been a number of
cases and i think every council with
properties
has experience of this and and they can
cause
considerable number of social issues uh
many of us in our wards will have come
across these
i just would like to know if we're going
to be able to get started on that again
yeah i can have that conversation with
the assistant director housing
and also his corporate managers to to
establish
what precautions we can take as we move
forward and how we can escalate those
because i'd imagine at the moment
obviously with the lockdown there's very
there isn't a huge amount we can do but
obviously we want to send out the right
message
that we actually haven't taken our eye
off the ball so that's something i can
discuss with
um kevin if i'm a counsellor it has in
fact been used as something of a get out
of jail free card i'm afraid
thank you catholic uh coach mclaren
please thank you chair
um john across ipswich
i know of at least four charities
that deal with or provide a money advice
service
which and having worked with one a lot
of it
is about council tax and housing benefit
is there any relationship between what
you're talking about
and is there any um joint training
with these sort of the organizations
themselves
uh it's a very good question i'm not
aware that there is but
interestingly taking that point forward
i could raise that through the suffolk
fraud group
it was a very valid point and to see
what
arrangements are in place across suffolk
and how we can actually
share best practice so i think that's a
very valid point councillor and if i may
have
i'll use that um that group to actually
raise that issue
thank you very much john that's
brilliant thank you
thank you very much uh council mclaren
um yeah i would i would also like to say
i'd like to
commend um john on this report um
again during the naughties i was
actually a dwp
fraud manager and i used to liaise on a
regular basis with my opposite number
it was at northampton borough council in
those days and i think some of the
points that councilman madison raised
again very very
relevant um certainly we would do
because you had joint
uh fraudulent claims normally with
income support or job seekers allowance
and housing benefit
we would always try to get maximum
publicity in the local press and i would
always liaise with the
dwp press office because we found if
we've got
maximum publicity then it surprised that
many people would sign off
um after a case had been reported
and and the other thing we would also do
is that um
if there was a large amount involved we
would try and ask the magistrate's call
to refer it up to crown court
for sentencing um and i presume that um
the srp or the four team in in isborough
council would do a similar thing
but i do commend john on liaising with
his colleagues in the other councils
i do think that's really really helpful
in trying to deter
any type of fraud so thank you for that
john do any other members have any other
questions
or council matheson
yeah just be before mr snell just
disappears
after um a good long run um
i think it would be reassuring and this
goes back to some extent to
the previous item on the agenda um that
if
if we had a um a reassuring report
to our august meeting um regarding the
staffing
um arrangements that he's putting
in place um that that would be good
thank you john
um can i just sort of clarify in terms
of what you're
looking for from me uh in terms of those
staffing arrangements
um are you looking for a report or just
um
an overview in terms of the audit
provision
uh as we're moving forward well i i
think just
a uh i can give you a paper
the external partnership arrangement has
has
started successfully on the july the
first and andy's
is um is delivering strongly
um maybe maybe one should look at the
um the practice of the
overview and scrutiny committees where
um
they do actually have a a so a bulletin
which um just updates updates the
committee
um without requiring discussions and and
votes and things um you know that that
maybe it's more in that context
if i could just come back very quickly
if i may counsel that um obviously if
you're talking about an update in
august and we're in july now
the external provider won't have
achieved a huge amount
of work um but what i do do
as you're aware is i provide counsellors
with a midterm half-yearly report uh
around about october november time so
that will give you a better vindication
in terms of the work that they've
undertaken and the um their findings
i just think it's a little bit sorry i'm
not trying to do it's just a little bit
too soon or so
you know i wouldn't be able to report
very much next month quite frankly when
we're all trying to
set up the work um as they move forward
obviously they're just coming back
um because obviously it's affected them
greatly the kovid 19
so they're just now touching base with a
lot of their own their other clients
uh we're a new client um and obviously
i've lazed with melissa who i believe is
on the line and we're sort of
almost sorting to uh two audits uh we're
looking at uh to start very very
um soon and i'll be in a better position
obviously october not in the time to
give you an
update in terms of where we are with the
work that they've undertaken
if that's um acceptable yeah that that's
that seems good if
i mean all i would say is if if if it's
not going well it would be
you know good to hear sooner rather than
later yes very much yeah obviously yeah
um i i would just provide a little bit
of assurance in terms
of the housing work that was uh
has been undertaken by the external
provider and the
quality of the work that has crossed my
desk in terms of the draft report
um has been very i've been very pleased
with the professions
and and also the report that they've
produced so
um and again i haven't had any adverse
feedback from the housing
people themselves and i look forward to
actually speaking with
gavin in terms of the findings of that
report and again that will be part of
the process that i'll report back at
midterm
but everything seems to be working well
at the moment so i'm very pleased with
how things are progressing
all right it's good to hear thank you
thank you councilman mccraw please
just to that point chair in scrutiny we
found that a minimum of six months
is usually required for any bulletin to
contain
data worth having uh and if it if the
data
hasn't been collected and doesn't
actually have any validity
there's no point in having it so we
would that's that's what we've found
yes i would agree with that uh
councilmember crawl do any any other
questions for members
no then we can now move into debate does
any other
member wish to debate this particular
paper
no okay well the recommendation which is
on page um
sorry council norris did you wish to
cancel norris
councillor norris
have you are you mute okay i'm sorry
it's very
delayed okay um so did you make wish to
ask a question
not really a point as such it just that
uh i've just spotted
actually something on the table on the
foot of page 85 which is continued on to
the top
fighter 86 the right hand column
is headed 2029 stroke
20 rather than 2019
it's just a typo thank you
thank you very much thank you counselor
norris uh counselor mccraw
thank you chair uh honestly i think the
simplest answer is that
this report is there to tell us that the
risk of fraud and corruption is being
managed
that's all it needs to do okay i think
it's done so adequate more than
adequately frankly
it's very relieving given the difficult
circumstances and the fact we've had
outside money coming in
and although we aren't able to exercise
our normal controls
uh we are able to have a look back
and make sure that nothing's gone wrong
but the speed has been of the essence so
i'd like to propose recommendation 2.1
as contained in the report
thank you case of court counselor
matthison yeah i thought i would second
it actually
chair thank you councillor matthewson
therefore could i ask the governance
officer to do the roll call please
thank you chair um councillors could you
please reply
for against or abstain councillor
amoroson
councillor lindsay four
councillor mccrore four councillor
mclaren
paul councillor matheson four
councillor mueller four councillor
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you very much indeed
uh right i'd like to move on to jsac
1919 the joint audit annual audit report
for 2018
19. i'm just trying to scroll down again
to find that on my papers um
and therefore i'd like to invite suresh
patel from external auditors ernst and
young to present the report to you
over to you suresh please thank you
chair and uh good morning to members of
the committee
um so our report on the 1819 account
starts on your page
91. um i think first and foremost just
worthwhile kind of recognizing how
uh incredibly frustrating uh it has been
in terms of getting the 1819
audit concluded um if you remember
at the end of january committee we were
kind of almost there
um and then we entered into the period
where covert 19
uh had impacted both in terms of
obviously our ability
in terms of the finance team as well as
the audit team's ability to
um interact uh face-to-face
but also then as i've alluded to in the
um in the paper
uh we have had to then consider the
impact of the coping 19 pandemic on your
actual
accounts and in particular you'll see a
focus on
what it means for financial resilience
and you're going to turn disclosure
hopefully you'll be pleased to know that
we have concluded that audit now
uh we are proposing to issue an
unqualified
opinion on the account and the clean
value from the conclusion
which is always a positive thing for the
council to receive
i should emphasize that the the impact
of the kobe pandem kobe 19 pandemic
like i said has been that you having now
included a detailed
disclosure note in terms of going
concern so um
the director assistant director of
corporate resources has carried out
a an assessment of the impact of the
pandemic
on your income your expenditure impacts
on balances and reserves
and that is now disclosed in your
accounts as it pertains to the 1819
accounts which
the going concern assertion that you
make in your accounts and the go and
concern
assertion that we make in our audit
report actually covers a 12-month period
from the date that those
accounts are finally approved which is
obviously um
sort of today or tomorrow when it comes
to the audit report so
so that that actually assessment uh has
been very helpful for i think for the
council in terms of the
um understanding the impact of the
pandemic and the disclosure
we are satisfied with we had to put that
disclosure and our order report through
a
internal eye consultation process
another impact of covert 19
because clearly we want to make sure
that we are given the right assurance to
the council and its stakeholders through
the audit report
uh and that was concluded late last week
um so it's worthwhile then
saying that in the report itself the
audit report which is on page 106 you
will see that we have included what's
called an emphasis of matter paragraph
to highlight the disclosures you've now
made around covid19
and just to be clear that emphasis
matter is not a
modification to the report or any form
of qualification it is as
as it says it is emphasizing to the
reader of the account an important
disclosure
that the council has made but like i
said that is not a qualification you are
receiving an
unqualified audit report um
chair i'll stop there and happy to take
any questions on this report
thank you very much suresh i noticed
coachella norris you've got your hand up
did you wish to ask a question of um
suresh please
no sorry i should have lowered that
earlier
thank you thank you country dodge uh
does any other member have a question
for suresh please
counselor matheson
thank you chair um yes if you could
um talk a little bit about the
um the liaison with the
with the auditors of our various group
companies
and um how the the
group accounts have been consolidated
into
the accounts of the two councils yeah
happy to do so um we'll probably give a
bit more detail when we talk about the
1920 audit plan as well because we
actually put an explanation in there but
but essentially yes we are responsible
for giving an opinion
on not only the each individual
council's accounts but also the
consolidated accounts that they prepare
so the group accounts
uh we take a view on whether or not we
think uh
the subsidiary companies are significant
either in terms of the size in terms of
turnover or assets that they hold
uh or in terms of any specific risk that
we that we consider to be relevant to
the group accounts
for the purposes of babe rumor suffolk
we identify i think it's sifco
and gateway 14 has been significant and
as a result
we actually place seek to place reliance
upon the audit of those companies by
as you as mentioned before by their own
auditors
uh so we engage with them we liaise with
them
we um we we we share our view on risks
and we have a discussion about risks
um and then we actually review the work
that they've done
on those accounts we receive their their
audit reports
uh to basically form a view from
ourselves whether or not we can rely
upon their work
uh and having done that we are then able
to issue
our opinion on the group accounts the
council obviously consolidates
uh each of those entities uh and i think
you you apply an equity share method so
you actually just recognize that your
share of profit or losses into your
accounts and we obviously ordered that
consolidation process to make sure
that your group accounts are maturely
accurate as i said we do refer to that
later on chair in the 1920 audit plan to
probably more detail but that is that is
essentially what we do in terms of the
the group accounts on the component
auditors
do you have a supplementary question
counselor matheson uh i'm
my brain is just just um processing
really um
yeah the yes i said yes the the
yeah if you could just explain a little
more
or possibly even catherine steele needs
to explain a little more
the the um the implications of recognize
equity share and um and and how
how the um balance sheet
the group balance sheet um which
presumably is somewhere where i haven't
looked yet
um how that how that reflects
i don't know if catherine wants to come
in on that one so it's your decision
about
uh taking the equity share method
catherine could i ask you to
mount that one place for john i was
going to say the decision was
made in terms of 10 equity goes into
cifco um but i wonder if this is a
discussion that we perhaps take offline
and provide a bit more information
obviously we haven't got the accounts
themselves in front of us and we will be
looking at the 1920 accounts in the
future
so i wonder if this is perhaps an area
that we we do take offline and perhaps
um
do it in terms of perhaps some training
around the accounts for
when we bring in 1920. i think that's a
very good idea catherine um
counselor madison are you happy with
that um
broadly yes the the um on the
presumably the 1819 accounts
um have got group consolidation etc in
them as well however
so is are our auditors um
yes comfortable with all of all of that
in the 1819 accounts
yes yeah i can confirm that um as i said
we're issuing an unqualified
uh opinion which includes the group
accounts
so we'll come back to the to the how the
consolidation of the
balance sheet and so on um works
either either on the
annual audit plan or more likely in a
training session then
thank you thank you um do we have any
other questions for suresh
no thank you very much suresh i would
like to comment it's an
excellent achievement to get unqualified
reports again i hop back to my time
working the department of health audit
and the audit commission and not once
did i come across a set of unqualified
reports
so well done to all the officers um for
their work to ensure
that everything is how it should be so
thank you uh council
crawl i just recall
chair um for suresh that uh at the last
time we met there were delays in the uh
industry in general that were affecting
uh audits across the country in a
variety of areas i
think you referred to it in what you
said then and i just wondered if that
this is unrelated in many ways but it
may relate to our
joint annual audit plan that we're going
to be looking at next so
just to get it out there right now um
has that situation
uh improved any um have has the backlog
been caught up with that the industry
itself was suffering
so it whilst it has improved
uh clearly the pressures haven't gone
away in terms of the underlying reasons
for those pressures which
if you recall was as you rightly say it
was a kind of industry-wide
uh challenge in terms of recruitment and
retention um
and whilst we as a firm have actually
recruited a significant number of new
additions to our teams
um that always takes a little bit of
time for those individuals to get
up to the right level of speed and
understanding but it has improved
but when we talk about 1920 um
we we've agreed a kind of a a phasing
program for all of the east of england
local authorities that we audit
um and that that that has an impact on
baby software
we'll talk about that in a second um so
so it is we are we're in a better
position
uh we still have a number of 18 19
audits that we have yet to close off and
covered as i said the impact of things
like going concern
uh emphasis and matter on audit reports
it hasn't helped because it's just added
an additional layer
of work and actually whilst um it's been
impressive actually both from
the finance professionals perspective
and also orders how we've been able to
operate
by working remotely that remote working
does still have an additional layer of
complexity and takes a little bit more
time than things would do normally when
you're just
face to face and asking questions to to
offices um
so so generally it has improved but
there are still remain challenges
i can't say we've noticed any time
delays here
sorry that was meant to be ironic my
apologies chair thank you councilman
mccraw
do any other members have any other
questions on this item
so now we we can debate the item
do any members we should debate this
item further
if if not then i recommend
um that i'm happy to propose a
recommendation on page
89 which the report is noted could i
have a second to please
happy to propose sorry thank you thank
you very much
um could i ask the governance officer
please to do a roll call of the members
for their votes please thank you chair
again councillors if you could reply for
against or abstain
counselor amber rosen
councillor lindsay four councillor
mccrore
councillor mclaren paul councillor
matheson
four councillor mueller port
councillor norris oh thank you chair
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed i now like to
move on to item number eleven uh
jac stroke 1921 the joint all annual
audit plan
and again i would like to invite suresh
patel from external auditors ernst
young to present the plan over to you
suresh please
thank you chair um so the report starts
on your page 117 and this as you say is
the
audit plan for the 1920 statement of
accounts
uh i'm going to just give you a bit of
an overview and then hand over to vicki
to take you through
in terms of what the key risk areas are
and areas of audit focus
um so i suppose following on from the
1819
uh closure of the audit and i mentioned
about the impact of kovid 19.
clearly that has then a following impact
on the 2019-20 accounts
and we have reflected on that in the
audit plan so a number of the areas
of audit focus which are either new or
enhanced
are as a result of the pandemic and
actually are reflected in virtually all
of our audit plans for local
government bodies so uh clearly the
issues that are impacting on your
uh financial reporting and accounts are
impacting across
across the board as i said before one of
the main ones is around
going concern and just to be clear it's
not about a challenge of are you going
concerned
about should there be disclosures around
that the
pressures and the potential risks around
your financial
position and performance going forward
um
a specific one that vicky will elaborate
on is around the valuation of certain
assets at the 31st of march 2020
given the volatility of of of market
data at that point in time
that does present a risk in terms of the
accounts
i've mentioned about ordered delivery in
terms of remote working
clearly we've been we've all been remote
working
since um since the late march uh and
again we've kind of learned some
good good good ways of working i suppose
from concluding the 1890 council with
your finance team to
enable us to deliver the well to enable
your finance team to prepare the
accounts but also
and then enable us to deliver the audit
um one of the other impacts of covert 19
has been that mhclg have
changed the timetable or reporting
which has been been helpful but as i
mentioned before
um we we've agreed with the east of
england
chief financial officers a phasing
approach to each of the audits for 1920
uh and that has meant that one will come
to your timetable florida
that has impacted abundant timetable
that we've now got in place
to deliver your audit i'll hand over to
uh to vicky who's going to take you
through the
overview pages thank you suresh
thank you chair thank you surash um i'm
pleased to present
um our 1920 outlet audit plan which is
how we intend to carry out our
responsibility
on page one two three and one to four of
the report
it set out the audit risk and aerial
focus for the order
just to highlight that there are no
changes in risk compared to last year
except for property plan and equipment
valuation as just mentioned by suraj
this is now a significant risk and it is
due to your decisions to change a valuer
from district valuer to
weeks ahead and eve and therefore from
the audit perspective
we need to obtain an understanding of
the work performed by the new valuer
including the valuations and methodology
and assumption used
and like mentioned as well the convert
19 pandemic
also has driven an increased risk
assessment on the ppe
in particular where asset will value
using market value
but we need note that this has less
impact for
social housing property in addition um
we also mentioned about how the pandemic
has um
impact on the going concern and as a
result
and because of the pandemic increased
pressures on the council finances in
1920
therefore it has led to one new area of
focus
which is gearing concern
like there are other combinating impact
we consider in the report which are
detailed in page one two four
including the remote working
arrangements and how we work with the
finance team to obtain the relevant
evidence for the audit and because of
the ongoing uncertainty combinating
presence to
the mature accuracy of the financial
statements our firm has introduced
consultation process
on all audit reports which means that
there
may be an impact on the timing on the
content of the audit reports that we
issue
i would also like to draw your attention
to the changes in the reporting time
scale announced by
magic clg which is just mentioned by
us rash that the council are required to
publish their draft account by 31st of
august
this has moved from the previous
dateline of 31st of may
and to publish their audited accounts by
30th of november
and this was moved from the previous
date line of 31st of july
and the council has initially planned to
prepare their drop account by
end of june and our audit work was start
in july
how however due to the common 19 there
are increased demands on
finance team to deal with the pandemic
and therefore the timeline to deliver
the drop account has
moved to early august now um
because we plan like just measure
because we plan and agree our audit
resources in the facing approach for
all our clients this means that we will
have to reschedule audit to a later date
which is to substantially start the
audit in early november
but we will commence our analytic work
some selections
accounts review and asset valuation work
during the summer
this is to ensure that we have a team
that has experience of the councils to
carry out the work
we will be aiming to complete the audit
by mid of december
and reporting a complete audit for the
january committee meeting
and then moving on is in terms of value
for money
we have considered combinating impact
and because
the lockdown was announced a week before
the year end
we have not identified a significant vfm
risk in relation to combat 19 at this
stage
so um we also mentioned about the group
warded
so we regard with regard to the scoping
of the group order in page 140 141
we confirm that we have now received the
information to conclude our scoping
which remained the same
as shown in the report i.e the full
scope
for both civco and gateway 14 due to the
sizes of these entities
and specific scope for msdc support
holding and btc support holdings
just to clarify clarify on the audit
scoping
a full scope is where a full audit is
performed by
the substitute auditor entities auditor
which is answers
at the maturity level set by us and also
on additional procedures that required
by us as a group audit team
while the specific school is limited to
specific accounts or disclosure that are
identified by us
we will review answer works and they are
reporting packages for the audit
so that brings to um the end of the
report
and just the final thing chao wanted to
highlight is around audit fees
which are on page 150 and 151
onwards you'll see there in the two
tables we've we've included what we
typically could do in terms of a range
of uh additional fees where we are
carrying out
work that's kind of outside the addition
the the normal kind of scale fee
but you'll also see reference to uh
our proposals to increase the actual
scale fee and this follows on
from uh uh uh issues that i've flagged
at earlier
committee meetings about um the kind of
uh the industry itself
and particularly the kind of local
public sector uh audit market and how
sustainable that is
we have been in dialogue nationally with
psaa about our view that
things have changed significantly since
2007
when the uh when the most recent tender
was awarded particularly around the
increase
requirements on auditors to meet
regulatory requirements set by the
financial reporting council
and we have then calculated what we feel
to be a
a more full and proper scale fee for
your two councils um we've also shared
the detail of that with
with your um assistant director of
corporate resources
and we know that she's discussing and
debating that with her colleagues across
um suffolk and the east of england in
terms of how their fees compare
that is again a like i said a national
dialogue that is happening
uh and we will update the committee uh
at the next
uh opportune moment in terms of when
psaa make
any determination on those fees again
we'll stop there and we're happy to take
questions chair
any questions for either vicky or suresh
please
councilman crawl please
sorry about that chair certain amount of
inevitability in this wasn't there
um actually i just wanted to address
something in the report that
particularly caught my attention
uh when i was going through it uh
large portion of the report refers to
materiality
materiality um i'll be honest i had to
look it up
uh and according to the dictionary
definition it relates to how what is
relevant
and important uh so one suggestion
i don't think materiality is exactly a
user-friendly word although i understand
we are all prone to a little bit of
jargon
but i was just going to suggest that
once the word materiality is in
in introduced into a report perhaps in
brackets it could say
relevant and important or whatever
definition
would be most helpful to anybody in the
public looking at it for example
or in fact any ordinary counsellor
but i would like to ask of anybody how
is that materiality the relevance and
importance assessed
when we assign numbers to it what is the
basis on which we are saying right that
is material and that is not
just some indication i understand you
can't be too specific
yeah that's a fair question and i think
that's also a fair comment about
um how understandable the term
materiality is and and we do
um have a regular challenge on trying to
make sure that
technical audit speak is is
understandable so i think your
reference to relevant important is
actually very useful so thank you for
that
so in terms of how we calculate it um so
on page one three
five we kind of give you a bit more
detail on on materiality
so i mean ultimately as you rightly say
uh
materiality is a and it's a professional
um
view that auditors express in terms of
what they deem to material
you might have your own view and and
actually officers
are encouraged to take a different view
to the auditor on what they deem to be
material
but essentially we have uh we we have an
option of choosing what we think is an
appropriate
uh benchmark in terms of what is
actually more relevant
to the uh to the entity that we're
auditing in terms of
um what we would then use to work out
materially so for the purposes of a
local authority
we choose gross expenditure as being the
most meaningful kind of benchmark in
terms of them
we would then calculate a percentage of
that gross expenditure
to work out what's material within ey we
have a sliding scale between two and one
percent
of gross expenditure to determine
limited energy for local authority
two percent reflecting our view that
actually um there's a
there's a lower profile in terms of your
accounts than if usa
if you if you were subject to kind of
various regularity
regulations reviews by um i don't know
uh offstage cqc whoever it might be
then we might drop down that to one
percent but two percent is a represents
a kind of higher level which is a
positive thing for the council
we then have to determine what's called
performance militarity which is in
essence
driven by the auditing standards that
say whilst you might set your planning
material to
several at a certain level you then need
to consider a lower level for your
testing so in effect
performance metallurgy is the level we
start thinking about what what will we
test
on your balance sheet or within your
income and expenditure statements
and again within ey our approach is to
argue 75
of that planning material to all 50 75
reflect in our view that actually your
accounts preparation processes are are
pretty good and we wouldn't expect to
find
many material misstatements in your
accounts if we did
think that the adverse to that that we
thought that your accounts preparation
process wasn't appropriate and there's a
high risk that we'd find material
misstatements then we would drop that
testing level performance maturity to 50
percent
so ultimately we have to have some way
of having a consistent approach
to id to calculate materiality and
that's the way we do the ey other firms
of work to have a slightly different
approach but ultimately
it's based on a percentage of an
appropriate benchmark
which for local authorities we deem as
being gross expenditure
thanks can i just follow up on that yes
certainly certainly
it's really just to say i think a lot of
people be very well very relieved that
the benchmark
uh based on turnover uh is as low as two
percent or even one percent because i
mean
that's a relatively small amount of
money and yet uh
that is being regarded as relevant and
important um it's quite important for
that
confidence to be established in in the
accounts
and and in the audit trail itself so
thank you very much for that
can i just ask one more question and
then i will shut up for a while
uh this is for our section 151 office i
know it's hard to believe that it can
happen um and that's just to ask on the
question of fees
um because obviously fees for audit uh
internal external whatever well external
certainly
must be part of the cost of doing
business after all this is a
a legal requirement we must do this i'd
just like to ask catherine if uh
if the scale of fees uh would be
something that she would regard in her
professional opinion
as reasonable for councils of our size
it's a simple yes and no i'm afraid
catherine it's not a complicated one
i don't know if i can just say yes or no
to it actually without without giving
just a little a little bit of context to
it
do the complicated version as though i'd
asked a proper question that wasn't a
simple closed question
we'll we'll go from there
i i'd certainly acknowledge the the
audit fees have come down too low
i think the scale fee planned for both
baber and mid suffolk is down in the 30
thousands
for 2019-20 accounts
and it wasn't that many years ago both
councils were paying close to a hundred
thousand so whilst the contract with
psaa
has obviously brought savings to the
councils
um my professional view is it has come
down too low now
so um i think we do need to increase the
fees
the conversation is um i think with psaa
and obviously with ey is how quickly we
put it up and to what level
but yes i believe it has come down too
low to give us the the quality
audit that we need of our accounts
those costs would not actually measure
up on the materiality scale then would
they
uh no thank you
thank you very much uh councillor
matheson please
thank you um if if i could ask vicky
chong
to um just run over one part again
there was a lot of detail there and my
brain doesn't work as fast as
probably her certainly um
you spoke about the scope of the audit
in relation to cifco and gateway 14.
could you kind of elaborate or go around
that again
yes sure um so
how we determine the scoping is actually
is
based on the sizes of the entity or the
risk of these entities
so difficult gateway has been assessed
that their blue scope is because
of um mainly because of the size because
civico
has around like 50 million in invested
in investment properties
and the nature of the business they run
which is
based on the rental income and um
and therefore the combat 19 in some way
will have some
impact on um you know um just
in terms of valuation of this property
gateway 14 is another one because
of the um land that purchased um
in close in 1780 or 1819
that which is around 60 million
that is under the development purpose
and again it's the size of that account
so therefore on that basis we have
assigned a full scope
so that you know we will rely on the
full audit that performed by ansels
and at the maturity level that we set
for them
and also on the additional procedures
that we require them to perform for
example
on their pp evaluations and going
concern as well
in light of the conflict 19. for
me for msdc suffolk ordering and bdc
suffolk holding
we assign them as a specific scope
because they
com in comparison they are smaller
entities compared to difficult and gap
wave warning
and therefore the risk is also um is
reduced in terms that is not as high as
compared to the other two entities
and that's the reason how we have
scopulum
thank you vicky do you have a
supplementary question casey matt um
the uh yeah my again my brain isn't
quite so fast
um yeah i think i think i
understand that
quite a lot better now
thank you um so we're saying that that
you're particularly concerned about the
covered impact on sifko
but the size impact of gateway 14
um i think my supplementary really is is
that do
um do you do you look at the
the various risk registers of the
council but also of the companies
we we as powerful planning and our
audience we do
look at the um corporate register
of the council and we would consider you
know how
um if there's any risk being flagged up
on the
risk register that we need to um take
into considerations in our audit work
yes um yeah of the
sorry the company the individual
companies have risk registers
but they're not being audited by
yourselves and then ultimately you need
to
consolidate them my understanding is
that um
your risk register will include if
there's any things
um back up on civical and gateway 14
that are significant
there will also be included in your risk
register as well
but but just to be clear uh councillor
yeah we we wouldn't
necessarily look at the risk registers
held by those individual companies
um but ultimately you would look at the
the asset valuation
the work that the the relevant other
auditor has
performed yes yes
okay thank you thank you very much john
um council mclaren please
thank you chair uh i'm not sure who
will answer this question and if i i
think i remember on
asking this question last year uh i want
to refer to the pension liability
valuation
um which shows that 2019 for baby it was
22.9 million
and i think i've seen some figures
somewhere for the march
2020 as pension funds are very much in
the news with kobit 19
um and thinking about the future
where do we sit so that's babe
um in a um
list of count you know do we compare
favorably to other councils within the
country
with a deficit um like these
um there isn't a national um
chart if you like in terms of how all
the different pension funds
are performing but we had a
revaluation as at it was march 2019
i think was the last triennial valuation
of the suffolk pension fund
and suffolk came out very well overall
nationally
um baber was around about 94 95
funded at that point in time so whilst
the
figure that you see in the accounts is a
large number
um we are relatively well
funded at the moment i know mid-suffolk
was slightly behind
baber but i think suffolk as a whole
the the pension fund is better funded
than others around the country
thank you very much thank you chair
thank you councillor lindsay please
uh thank you chair it was it was just
too hard to
um to that answer because i'm on the
so i'll switch my camera on i'm on the
pension fund
committee at suffolk and um
if council mclaren would like sort of
some more detail they actually
the last um is publicly available in the
um
the papers to the committee they did a
uh
a little run through all the the local
authority pension funds in the country
and where we sat
for different uh measures um
and we we were things have changed since
since the end of the year because
because of the um
financial crash but we're still we're
still holding up you know
but that's um as catherine said that's
for suffolk as a whole for all the
pension okay
within that where there isn't a
breakdown of baba or mid suffolk
but that's if you if you look on the
county council website for
papers to the pension committee that
should be should be on there i don't
think that was in the
confidential section thank you very much
lindsay that's very helpful
yeah uh counselor mattis and then catch
them across please
yeah thank you that the um
it seems to come back to me that the on
the pension deficit
um that in the minutes
um we we
were told that we would eliminate the
deficit in three years but i guess
that um catherine steele might want to
re-advise on that in the light of the
you know subsequent events let's say
catherine did you want to take that
point out please yes thank you chair
obviously that was the view of the
actuaries based on march 19
valuation that they did the next one
will be as at march
22 say because it's a three-year
evaluation
so we will have to wait and see what the
fund position looks like and what world
events and world economy looks like at
that point in time so
i'm sure there will be some impact and
be surprised if the economy is back to
where it was by march 22
but we have to wait until we actually
get to that point and then see
see what the position looks like thanks
thank you catherine okay so matheson did
you wish two houses supplementary
no thank you oh thank you okay lindsay
you've got your hand raised again
sorry chair just forgot to lower it okay
uh
counselor maths and you've raised your
hand again have i
yes i don't think well
you got no other questions
thank you madison do any other members
have any other questions on this paper
you know do you wish do any members wish
which debate this this
item further before we look at the
recommendation
thank you very much well the
recommendation on page 115
is that the report is noted and any
comments on the report are fed back to
ernst young
i'm happy to propose that recommendation
could i have a second to please
counselor mclaren
yes i wish to support the proposal and
the recommendation
sorry thank you occasionally mclaren um
can i ask the governor's officer please
to do the the roll call for the vote
please
thank you chair councillors please reply
for
against or abstain councillor ameroson
or councillor lindsay
paul councillor mccrore for
councillor mclaren for councillor
matheson
or councillor muller for
councillor norris or thank you chair
that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed i'd now like
to move on to the
final item of the agenda which is agenda
item
number 12 uh jac stroke 1921 the forward
plan
and i would now like to invite john
robinson the corporate manager for
democratic services
to present the plan please chan over to
you
thank you chair um this report is just
a a standard forward plan and what we've
done is we've gathered up the
the information of all the um plans and
reports that come forward in a year and
put them in a plan
so that um councillors are aware of what
is coming up
just to point out that we do have an
additional committee on the 11th of
august
and that will cover the end of year risk
position treasury management out turn
and consultation on the new
model code of conduct and that's all i
have to add it is just for noting thank
you
thank you very much do we have any
suggestions comments or amendments
from members please uh i've got
mary you've got your hand up
sorry sorry chair that was my mistake
okay suresh
please yeah jake was just to
uh flag that i think in the i'm
you got it in september the statement of
account report 20 19 20. that needs to
move to january chair in light of
the timetable that we discussed in the
plan thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you are all
members happy with that moving that item
from
september to january
suresh did you wish to come back at all
sorry no no that's fine okay
um therefore that uh do any other
members have any questions or anything
on on the particular plan
no thank you very much oh sorry
[Music]
we had i had in my diary another date
for
for our committee to meet next week in
the afternoon
is that was that just a reserve date
when we were
well i got that completely wrong no it's
the 11th of august tuesday the 11th of
august is our next
next meeting uh council lindsay
any other questions no okay
yeah sorry counselor matheson
yeah the the i was just looking to um
to reassure myself that some of the the
outstanding issues that have been
highlighted
um early in the um in the meeting
really stemming from the minutes um that
we'll get those
um they'll find their way into an agenda
item
in august or september um
don't necessarily need to see them here
now but um that they will
appear thank you okay thank you madison
okay that therefore that the audit and
standards plans for baby and mid-suffolk
are noted
uh and therefore this concludes today's
meeting so i'd like to thank
um everyone that's taken part in today's
meeting for their
uh contributions and i wish you all a
good afternoon
i'll see you all on the 11th of august
thank you very much everybody
you